social media is buzzing about eating for longevity
thanks to the new Netflix show about Blue Zone so
what are the diet secrets of communities that
live to a 100 years young well let's bust out
that Veno baby cuz we're going to find out
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen today I'm going to be eating a blue zone
of improv diet and discussing how specific dietary
patterns may help you live into the triple
digits but before we get started don't forget
to subscribe and also check out my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook in the description below
for some balanced meal inspiration I can't promise
that you'll make it to 100 with these recipes but
it's definitely an evidence-based chance so super
quickly here blue zones is a term coined by Dan
Butner to capture the specific geographical areas
in the world with the most centenarians AKA the
greatest concentration of people who are living
past 100 so the five blue zones include okanawa
in Japan NOA in Costa Rica accaria in Greece
Sardinia in Italy and lomalinda in California
and despite being situated literally all around
the globe there were nine major similarities or
pillars in these communities as it pertains to
movement outlook on life diet and connection
I'm going to explain these with some examples
as we go along but let's hop until breakfast
because your girl is hungry so according to Dan's
research a really Common Thread amongst a lot of
the blue zones is the frequent consumption
of coffee especially as a social experience
with family and friends love this journey
for us because as you guys know I need my
coffee and apparently in aaria Greece they boil
their coffee grounds instead of filtering them
which is said to just kind of like increase the
beneficial antioxidants which are associated with
a reduced risk of chronic disease interesting as
for breakfast we are going to NOA Costa Rica for
something called Gallop Pinto so basically we
got some black beans we got some rice salsa all
cooked together and then you can add in whatever
veggies you've got I've got some bell peppers and
some frozen squash and then sometimes it's served
with eggs which I'm going to do to add a little
bit of protein in there but sounds super simple
and delish so in the show Dan talks a lot about
the importance of beans and legumes across
blue zones especially in in Costa Rica the
Mediterranean and in the vegetarian community
of lomalinda California and this totally makes
sense as one that he found that people lived in
extra eight years for every ounce of legumes that
they ate it also makes sense because we've
all learned from a very young age that beans
beans are good for the heart and I don't know I
will take a little bit of farting for good heart
health plus a huge bonus in this economy
when animal costs are literally through the
roof okay so this was insanely easy to make
Brody you get one I get one cuz in the blue
zones it's all about Community it's all about
sharing so grab that grab that let's take a
little taster it is hot as hell it's actually
pretty good very easy to drink I I didn't even
put anything in it it's got like a nice smooth
taste to it I love that bib up because I this
is the wrong outfit for this meal I made him
extra sloppy for me I know how you skid like
them sloppy that is so good the rice I wouldn't
have thought i' do the rice but the rice I'm here
for it's good you know normally whenever I
eat breakfast or lunch I'm like sitting here
scrolling through Tik Tok or reading comments or
answering emails on my phone Etc but today we're
living like the Blue Zone and that means really
making an effort to slow down live presently in
the moment and making major efforts to reduce
stress and I don't know reading vicious troll
comments as I try to have a basic meal isn't
exactly relaxing nor is excessive social media
use generally good for public health so bye-bye
loging off it's going to be a lonely meal but I
think I'm going to enjoy it m m m coffee first
now family is also a huge part of the blue zones
there's a lot of generational housing going on
and taking care of one's Elders is really built
into the culture so like they don't put granny
in a nursing home when they can have her move in
with the rest of the gang get me out of here I'm
not sure I'm ready for that but I can give Grandma
sharp a call I guess I got to turn on my phone for
this Grandma where are you hi Ma happy birthday
yeah you want to come by like oneish we got a
hole we got a hole in a stuffy we need to deal
with major emergency yep yep okay love you bye
it is officially soup season and despite living
in yearr round gorgeous Sunshine the sardinians
Apparently love their Minon soup and I love that
because it is a built-in hunger crushing combo
with the beans that we discussed and lots of fiber
and antioxidant Rich veg and honestly one of my
favorite meditative activities is to make soup so
one of the tenants of the blue zones is to live
with purpose whether that's investing in faith
spirituality advocacy work or passion and cooking
has really always been a passion of mine and it's
one that I rarely get to exercise now that I have
kids so making slow food like soup to me can be a
really meditative ative experience now another
thing that Dan points out is that folks in the
blue zones are not low carb they eat carbs they
love life especially the Italians they do however
focus on higher fiber or fermented carbohydrates
more often so things like sweet potatoes in the
okaga uh whole grains in lomalinda and sourdough
Breads in Sardinia and again this makes sense yuck
because the research suggests that folks who
eat the most fiber reduce the risk of dying
by 23% compared to those who eat the least now I
feel like a whole grain bread would be slightly
higher in fiber to pair with a little soup action
but I am personally obsessed with sourdough and
it's uniquely beneficial because the fermentation
increases the bioavailability of the nutrients it
also lowers the gluten and the bread's glycemic
index while feeding the good bacteria which is
also associated with longevity okay so I know you
guys were cring ining with how full I just packed
that pot but I pulled it off guys and I used
up all the left of reng in my fridge so that
is a very big win in my books another big win is
how ridiculously delicious and nutritious this
looks that is so good oh that flavor just like
it's been cooking all day long a little dunk I'm
not scared of s I'm crying cuz it's good but also
cuz I definitely burnt the roof of my mouth worth
it all right it is cool but it's not raining
outside which is a huge bonus for a fall here
in Canada so I feel like this calls for some
joyful movement and this is really Central to
the experience of communities in different
blue zones so movement is intuitively and
naturally built into their day often from doing
like functional activities like gardening or
dancing in the evenings or just like walking up
and down steep streets from the markets now I'm
lucky to live in a somewhat walkable City so I
do try to walk whenever possible and I do know
that safe spaces for exercise are a privilege
so obviously please just do your best with where
you live poppy Poppy's my guard dog here she's
not very good at it probably if we were to get
into trouble I would be the one rescuing her
but the girl needs to walk so let's move our
bodies come on pops okay let's get started on
dinner here in inspired by okanawa Japan so in
the show they reveal that purple sweet potatoes
make up about 67% of the okanawa diet talk about
not keto now purple sweet potatoes apparently have
about twice the antioxidants as you know regular
sweet potatoes thanks to the bright colorful
anthocyanin compounds so I looked far and wide
for a purple sweet potato I literally called 20
different grocery stores apparently they're not
easy to find here in Canada so I did have to just
settle for the regular old yam actually this is a
sweet potato just a regular one but anyway that's
going to be my base and then on top I'm going to
do some kind of like stir fry situation with tofu
and some veg in there plus some miso soup on the
side minimally processed plant-based proteins
like tofu are really popular in the blue zones
where generally meat consumption is quite low and
again this totally makes sense soy products are
rich in antioxidants called isoflavones which help
to reduce the risk of heart disease and even some
cancers like breast endometrial colon stomach
and prostate cancer and fermented soy which is
something that youd find something like miso is
associated with greater lifespan this looks and
smells amazing and really could not be simpler to
pull off super inexpensive super great for just
using up whatever little leftovers and goodies
you've got that is good another concept that
is Central to the okan food philosophy is is
something called harachi boom which not only
sounds super adorable but essentially it means
to eat until about 80% full in Dan's words it
allows us to feel satiated without stuffed now
when we think about our hunger and soti cues I
do think that for a lot of people it can be
helpful to use the hunger fullness scale and
harachi Buu is probably not going to feel
the same to everyone and I also don't think
that we need to make a hard and fast rule of
like 80% but the idea here is to listen to
your body and until content rather than letting
yourself get to the point of feeling stuffed and
uncomfortable oh how have I not made miso soup
from a packet before this is so good all right
lovely last but not least my favorite course
dessert and we are living our best lives here
because that is what we do in the blue zones so
that means a little Veno and I picked myself up
these little Greek honey donuts called lum lumu
luku mes lukumades lukumades please don't please
don't kill me guys I I'm not Greek and that
is hard to say lumu lumu lumu cadis lumads
Google embarrassing let's let's listen lumu
CAD pronounce it l oh ladis ladis lukumades
how do you say it lukumades okay lukumades
I got that and they look delicious they're
basically like little honey soaked Donuts
I mean how can you go wrong with that and
I got me some red wine what am I doing oh Abby
this is so embarrassing I didn't even I didn't
even take the the amate move I didn't even take
the the wrapper off put it right I wasn't paying
attention I was just talking yeah we will fix
this guys we will fix this problem I haven't
even had anything to drink yet this is a problem
all right let's screw in again that's what she
says anyways back to honey so honey is actually
huge in the blue zones because it's rich in
antioxidants and it's been associated with lower
blood pressure and heart health ditto with the
wine um moderate wine consumption is also a
very common fixture in a lot of blue zones
again likely because of its antioxidants
levels which basically LED itself to this
j-shaped curve we see with alcohol consumption
benefits and risk so there's like a sweet spot
of about 100 gram of alcohol per week or about
six glasses of wine per week where we see the
lowest risk of heart disease or death folks who
completely abstain have slightly higher risk and
those who drink a lot more have significantly
higher risks I personally don't Advocate trying
to get your antioxidants from wine but what
I do think maybe really important and maybe
playing into this longevity enhancing role
here is that with with that glass of wine
often comes human connection and socializing
so one teaching that I find is quite consistent
across blue zones is a recognition that social
connection is really important for our health
in the okanawa they call moay having a group
of five friends in LMA Linda they've got a
very strong faith-based community and they've
got like shared choir practice and in Sardinia
they live with multiple Generations Under
One Roof now research consistently shows
that social relationships and Community actually
extend our life so I say eat your dessert laugh
with your friends and family and enjoy life
and on that note Brody I know it's a Tuesday
night but I feel like we deserve this little
dut action look how cute these little things
are that is good oh this is a good pairing and
I didn't even know it m honey and red wine they
best friends and that my friends takes us to the
end of the day and I don't know if the wine is
talking but honestly I feel great obviously
longevity is a very complicated topic and I
had a lot of fun testing out some staple meals
and habits from the blue zones we have covered
a lot of points throughout the day but I want
to quickly recap on the nine pillars of the
Blue Zone lifestyle that likely contribute to
their long vibrant lives joyful movement living
with purpose stress reduction mindful eating
focusing on Plants moderate wine consumption
belonging to a community putting Family First
and investing in social networks all I know is
that Toronto is in no way conducive to most of
these pillars so I might need to start learning
like Italian or Greek but on that note that
is all that I have for you guys today if you
are from a blue zone or who have visited one
I would love to hear your thoughts and EXP
experiences in the comments be sure to subscribe
and I will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye